Speaker 1: Our The David Pakman Show separate
it is now.
It's amazing what's going on.
Over 31000 of our viewers are now subscribed
for free at David Pakman dotcom Reddit.
I want to look at a few posts I saw this morning.
User JP Denzil's posted in response to our
segment about apparently Marjorie Taylor Greene,
the Republican congresswoman, just learning
that the Holocaust was really bad.
JP denies these posts, yet people are just
as or even dumber than Marjorie Taylor Green
on the Holocaust writing Me and David are
both Jewish.
So we learn pretty extensively about the Holocaust
and the reasons it happened.
But very few other people really know what
it was or how it happened.
Some people think all the Jews were just put
in gas chambers.
Some think it was only Jews in Germany that
were attacked in a recent poll.
Twenty five percent of young New Yorkers believe
Jews caused the Holocaust.
Now, I looked that study up.
It's actually 20 percent of young New Yorkers.
But that's true, 20 percent of young New Yorkers
believed that the Jews caused or were responsible
for the Holocaust.
And the point here is that JP Denzil's says
my shock at how uninformed Greene was and
probably still is about the Holocaust is actually
not that rare.
Her her lack of knowledge about the Holocaust
is not that unusual.
If that's true, that's extraordinarily disturbing.
I'm not saying that that it's it's untrue.
It actually very well may be true.
One of the things I've learned in doing this
show is if you overestimate the intelligence
of the American people, you are often disappointed.
And that's really how we got Trump.
Many people said that there's not enough stupid
people in this country that they're going
to elect Trump.
And then the Republican primary voters chose
him and then so so did the American people.
So, yeah, I think the big lesson from doing
this show is do not overestimate the intelligence
of the American people.
Another post about yet another airline flight
rerouted this one from or to San Francisco,
rerouted because of an argument over Elbo
placement on armrests and it listen, elbow
placement on armrests is a conflict you have
to figure out do you share?
Someone gets the front of the armrest and
someone gets the back or whatever, the airline.
You know, it's not road rage.
It's air rage.
It is crazy what is going on.
I have a bunch of flights coming up.
I am going to do everything I can.
And this is my commitment to you right now.
I'm going to do everything I can to avoid
getting involved in any such incident.
Yeah, let's see if I succeed.
And then lastly, I love this.
We had a call the other on Monday from a horrible
anti-Semitic military veteran and Reddit user
Baron Steuben posted, Progressive veterans
don't let people like the one in the voicemail
or the traders on January 6th give veterans
a bad name.
Plenty of us are proud progressives who want
to help make this country better for everyone.
Organizations like Common Defense and Vote
Vets embody this goal and should be in the
public eye more.
I am very much aware of that.
We have a lot of progressive veterans in our
audience.
More veterans voted for Joe Biden, the Democratic
candidate, in the last election than have
voted for any Democratic candidate in a long
time.
I don't falsely believe that veterans are
this conservative monolith.
There are many conservatives in the military,
just like in law enforcement, but there are
plenty of progressive veterans and appreciate
the message of support.
You can join the discussion at David Pakman
Dotcom.
Read it